[Music]
this shot is a rough version of the
final battle in avengers end game
and it looks pretty similar to what you
saw in theaters but the process of
putting this rough shot together began
three years before the movie came out
well before the actors went on set and
before a
single frame was captured on camera
these rough shots
are called previs short for
pre-visualization
essentially this tool allows filmmakers
to digitally map out how they want any
given scene to look
directors can then use the previz as a
guide for how to film scenes
sometimes frame for frame once
everyone's on set
[Music]
previz has been around for a long time
but in earlier movies
it was used in a much more limited way
they were used
for just small pockets of that movie
for the one big visual effects shot for
the big finale sequence
but now instead of just using previz in
small doses
companies like the third floor have
developed it into a tool for designing
entire movies and no studios embraced
that approach more than marvel
which has enlisted the help of the third
floor for 19 of the 23 films in its
infinity saga
for 2014's captain america the winter
soldier marvel had gotten to the point
of pre-visualizing two-thirds of a movie
today the studio is known to use
visualization to map
out every single scene not just action
scenes either
for endgame the third floor's work
touched everything from the comedic
scene with hulk in the diner
to emotional moments like the one
between hawkeye and black widow on
vormir
leaving nothing up to chance and one of
the most expensive movies ever made the
first visualizations of a marvel film
will often begin before the scripts
fully finished and that actually is the
best place for a professional
visualization team
is to be able to make bridges and try
out some experiments
between departments that have a crazy
idea that may or may not work you know
you want to be able to throw things at
walls and see if they stick
occasionally rough previs might be
underway even before the cinematographer
or director has signed on to the project
a practice that can be controversial in
hollywood
director lucrecia martell said she
turned down the offer to direct the
upcoming black widow movie
after marvel told her not to worry about
the action sequences
it is true that marvel encourages their
team of previz artists to play an
active role in story development jeff
ford the editor for endgame said that
the third floor's visualization
supervisor gerardo ramirez who'd worked
on nine prior marvel films was like an
additional director
writer and editor on the project that's
because previz artists are involved in
just about
everything from the start helping to map
out story beats and shots and consulting
on everything from
blocking staging lighting how heroes
will use their power in big fights
and even the timing and tone of any
given scene
to understand just how crucial previs is
to marvel's process
let's go back to that final battle from
endgame specifically
the avengers assemble moment when all
the heroes return
one by one through portals the third
floor presented marvel with
two previous takes on that arrival
moment one was slower and
more emotional while the other was
higher energy and had the heroes
arriving
mid-charge ultimately marvel went with a
blend of the two versions
a lot of this is done to save money
today's previz tools allow filmmakers to
do virtual location scouting
and test out advanced camera work take
for example the sony marvel movie the
amazing spider-man
which was shot in 3d the filmmakers
wanted to have some
cool first-person shots of spider-man
swinging through new york but they
didn't want to make audiences nauseous
so they used previs from the
visualization studio proof
to determine how much and what type of
movement people would be able to handle
all of this is then extracted into a
blueprint for production called techviz
which provides filmmakers with all the
data and diagrams they'll need to
actually recreate each shot in real life
essentially this is where all the
detailed math happens remember this
scene from thor ragnarok where heimdall
leads the asgardians across the bridge
the third floor did the techviz for that
crane shot to work out the camera height
and lenses they'd need along with the
distance from which they'd film the
characters
for endgame they produced over 100
different technical mock-ups containing
information like this
all of it accurate to the real locations
and equipment they'd be using
getting all the numbers down pat is
especially important for a movie like
ant-man where characters dramatically
fluctuate in size from one moment to the
next or
doctor strange where the folding city
imagery required a lot of dimensional
mathematics
and techviz is useful for quieter beats
too marvel used it to define the camera
parameters for this weighty scene
between
hawkeye and black widow in endgame to
make sure they'd hit the right tone and
visual impact
filmmakers can even plug the data from
techviz into a motion control camera
system
which lets you program precise
repeatable camera movements they're also
well-versed
in programming robotic dollies
robotic cranes that move the camera
around
setting up such a tightly controlled
shooting environment can speed up
production a lot
and when you're on location for a marvel
movie every minute counts
[Music]
the visualization process doesn't end
with shooting though the third floor's
work on a marvel film can run all the
way up to the end of post-production
because of the process called post fizz
this involves taking the live-action
photography they've shot and combining
it with the previz elements
take this moment in end game where
strange spider-man and star-lord join
the final battle
the third floor started with completely
digital previz and techviz for the shot
which marvel then used to film the
actors on a green screen
next the third floor reintroduced some
key previz elements like the background
and the outline of the portal
for endgame the third floor's artists
made 7
300 previz shots over 7000 of those
ultimately became post-fizz shots
the post biz shots serve as placeholders
in early cuts of the film
allowing marvel to quickly preview it
before commissioning the finishing
effects
marvel will often screen these versions
of the film filled with post biz
in front of test audiences to get an
idea of how the film might be received
plus the post biz shots provide a
template to the vfx artists
who take on the movie's final effects
work using visualization from beginning
to end can save marvel
millions on expensive effects and shoots
and ultimately
having all the technical stuff squared
away will ideally free up the director
to focus on getting the best
performances from their actors on set
they can be warned about things that are
up and coming that
might impact their craft so they're not
surprised about it
when they walk onto the set but doesn't
having all of these shots pre-rendered
diminish the role of directors on marvel
movies
not necessarily another advantage of
in-depth visualization
is that marvel isn't limited to hiring
big action directors
the studios become known for their
unconventional director choices
often pulling talent from the indie or
tv circuit
and that's where they can really benefit
also from the previous process
as they can trust a team like ours to
work with the stunt coordinator so all
they have to do is be
like an avid viewer of their own film as
it's coming together and to be
making comments like they do with
everything else some directors might
chafe at marvel's wide-ranging use of
previz
others may welcome the fact that marvel
has a dedicated team of previz artists
and vfx specialists who know how to plan
out action sequences
marvel's extensive use of visualization
has helped the franchise maintain
a coherent vision all the way through
endgame given marvel's box
office dominance other studios may
follow their model of embracing
visualization
even for smaller productions the third
floor has worked on a number of
non-action films in recent years
from art flicks like 2016's nocturnal
animals to political biopics like
2018's vice now that the digital world
is merging in with the physical world
that
is going to be the future of a lot
larger swath
of content creation than just these very
ambitious productions
[Music]
you